[Applause]
all right everybody we have time for one
more uplifting story this is what I'm
liking so this month the Miss America
Pageant made history when for the very
first time they crowned an active duty
military officer as the winner
22-year-old second Lieutenant Madison
Marsh isn't just a pilot but that's so
cool uh she's also a graduate student at
Harvard sure and check out her interview
just before she won the pageant so as m
America it says that you want to go on
the Kelly Clarkson show so let's pretend
you're walking out as Miss America Kelly
Clarkson show what is your message as
Miss America to all of those young girls
out there they can do anything that they
want they can be Miss America they can
be a military member they can be a
doctor lawyer you name it and I think me
being able to be there Echoes that to
women all around the world and that's
exactly what I want to do and capitalize
on in my international plan with at the
Air
Force in love with her I also honored to
help her spread her message let's
welcome your 2024 Miss America's second
Lieutenant Madison
Marsh she
is M
[Music]
Amica so crazy it is amazing that's what
you've accomplished that nobody else
first of all thank you so much for your
service
for I mean this you think this is more
than a win for you though right
absolutely I mean I kind of talked about
a little bit how it goes more than just
me winning and how I feel like I get to
represent all women yeah women in the
military being able to show like we can
break boundaries and that femininity can
be a superpower and you use that to be a
leader and they don't have to be
separated separate because I think
people do that you're either this or
that and you can be both I love that
message yeah so there was a very
important thing for you to be honoring
your mom through this whole process
right mhm so I lost my mom to pancreatic
cancer in 2018 she was only 41 years old
and was
misdiagnosed um and we had no cancer
history in our family she didn't have
any of the warning signs and so when she
passed away I saw how much she would
have given to be here to have her life
and her love shared with everyone and I
know that I have an incredible
opportunity every day each day that I
get is an opportunity that my mom and
other pancreatic cancer patients didn't
have so that's why we started the
Whitney yeah so that's why we started
that Whitney Marsh Foundation um so
basically we raise money for Pancreatic
Cancer Care advocacy and the patients uh
we do a 5k 10K every year for my mom
she's a big Runner I mean when she was
going through chemotherapy that woman
was running 10 miles oh my gosh what a
superhero mom I know I know yeah that's
incredible thank you so much for being
just s such a powerful influence for
young women and young men like anybody
can do anything they want to do you can
achieve it it's just such a cool thing
and what a a a barrier to break that
nobody even really maybe realized was
there but like yeah you can be both
things you can be beautiful and powerful
and you represent that so thank you for
doing that yes there's so many young
people thank you Madison I'm liking her
post right now that is not all though
our season long partner pilot pin makers
of precise the go-to kedy Kelly Clarkson
show want to honor truly Unstoppable
people just like you and your mama so
they are going to be riding the Whitney
Marsh Foundation a check for $1,000
oh thank you so much you
[Music]
are back anytime than So yeah thank you
to all of our guests this hour Christy T
David Shan bianc valer monz for and
Rachel monz minor you have a great day
and if it's not change
[Music]
it
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home